all right Briana Briana where'd you grow
up are you from I'm from Pasadena
Pasadena what and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents
growing up
no I didn't and I lost my mom at a young
age she was addicted to drugs and I
never knew my father never knew you dad
so who raised him my auntie what I
considered to be my mom and how was your
childhood
um myself that was pretty good mmm no
abuse nothing like that no then what can
I kid were you in high school I'm so
like in high school I know it is
we're like actually when I was like 13
my mom told me I had to live man and I
didn't realize what she meant and so I
actually 316 your aunt told you this
mm-hmm told you why I let her have a way
with man you have a way with men yeah
yes I'm sure you do what does that mean
um so once I became 16 I realized that I
kind of had a the guys liked you
yeah like older you know generous
gentlemen were a chuckles me and what
did that what did that mean in terms of
what kind of interactions were you
having um when I was from 16 to 18 I
didn't technically have sexual
intercourse with any of my clients but
after 18 definitely in there where were
you working if I don't figure out yes I
work on a couple blame so south-central
yes and were you working with the tamper
on your own on my own and your own and
your ever had a pimp yeah yeah how much
money would you make or do you make um I
make I like ten established clients um
so like I make anywhere from like 10 15
bands like a week
Jose like what's totaling all my
allowances together so you have regular
is it yeah so rather than picking up
strangers you're picking up your same
dude yeah seven like 16 18 I was just
like out and bringing
I really didn't know any like other
homing fowls and the my cousin
introduced me to like posting ads and
meeting guys like off the internet yeah
so so - today are you like on the street
still or are you basically just doing it
over the phone
no I like both like mainly really the
streets more just because everything
that's the one line it's not so popular
to child like set up a date online it's
more easier for them just pick me up
yeah have you have bad experiences -
guys I pick you up yes I have what kind
of stuff has happened um one time I was
I feel like I was kidnapped by three
guys um one of them actually hit me in
my face so like um like you're like kind
of Ramat eyes me like a bit it made me
really like scared of man and like you
know just living in a predicament that I
was living in me on the street it's like
hoeing or you know like having mmm it
like staying at people's houses or like
sleeping with them in hotels and things
like that
yeah they'd been arrested before yeah I
don't have a record at all when guys
pick you up where do you guys typically
go to a car to a hotel whatever is
convenient
yeah whatever gets me more money if you
have kids yes I have a three-year-old
son and your is him yes
so you started at what age at 16 16 and
our drugs a part of the picture for you
of course which drug is you oh I love
cocaine so are you doing crack or just
no just cooking just pattern okay
I'm smoking weed of course of course and
liquor you know does your family know
you do this
oh my dear Andrew yeah like you'd have a
choice um I got arrested but it wasn't
for hoeing and I need it her to go get
in my car and my money from like one of
my sugar daddies so I had to kind of
start like hey you gotta go see this guy
and he pulled up and she's like he was
white you know like what is this
obviously being 29 now uh I would have
rather preferred a different reaction
from what I got but it was just kind of
like okay you know like her mom was a ho
and it's secure both of us you know like
of course my benefits for her benefits
this is lifestyle get you down sometimes
do you depressed um yeah I'm saying when
I take my son I'm like on dates with me
and things like that
yeah it really like you know it gets to
me like before I was okay when he was
like an infant you know he's in his car
seat boom you know go from house to
house feeling me on I um but sometimes I
would have to leave him in the car
I wanna get in another car but it was
pretty easy back then now he's three and
he's like oh is this ha ha
you know like look where you died what
are you doing you know
yeah that part let me solve something
how do you think working the streets has
changed
uh I mean he's realized that like mm-hmm
like things that I was taught growing up
in my childhood
we're just like [ __ ] you know
because you I mean go to high school and
graduate but I was a high school diploma
compared to making thousands of dollars
a night and I look at it like if they're
not gonna pay me they're gonna play
somebody else all right
sorry are you happy with this lifestyle
um you think you're happy he's no I
think I
I think I'm more self forced myself to
be happy with the lifestyle just because
of all the accommodations and perks that
it comes with you know I think I've had
encounters with celebrity the South had
encounters with rappers having tell me
so it's pretty serious
I've been to a ton of swinger parties I
mean they porno with pinky the porn
stars so like at the age of 21 so like I
kind of just dived in headfirst so you
have these races as ever
mm-hmm definitely I was saying but I
would say like a probably weren't good
ones than bad you know like I feel like
I am fair so whatever I do never have
any bad intentions you know when I meet
a guy I'm not thinking like oh I'm gonna
rob him or get over on him like I'm just
like you do your part is my part well
gossip like you like me to call me a
game have you been in love before I
guess and do you find this lifestyle
doing this for a living gets in the way
of that definitely yeah
I would think a guy would have a hard
time you know what advice would you give
a young girl who's thinking about doing
this I was alright who know what she's
doing
I mean you don't get so many options in
life so if this is one of your options
it's not about one all right Briana
thank you so much for sharing your your
story and good luck with wherever your
life goes from here thank you thank you
you